Troy and Gabriella are a match made in
heaven but that doesn't make
long-distance dating any easier can
these high school sweethearts make it to
the finish line or will life get in the
way keep watching to find out if the
lovebirds stay together after graduation
listen babe I wouldn't sing with you if
my hair was on fire and you were the
last bucket of water on earth how things
left off you don't get to choose who you
fall in love with and sometimes
relationships can put a damper on your
life plans this is a reality that
gabriella knows all too well despite
being in love with Troy and wanting to
spend her life with him Gabriella had
dreams before she met him and throwing
them out the window for a boy just
wasn't her style so she chose to break
things off with Troy and attend the
Stanford freshman Honor program but
something about her decision just didn't
feel right by the end of High School
Musical 3 senior year many of us were
scared that Troy and Gabriella wouldn't
be together but luckily true love
prevailed however before love could run
its course
Gabriella called Troy to inform him that
she would not be coming home for
graduation or prom this sad phone call
was almost too much for Troy to bear so
he let his inner romantic come out and
went to Stanford a university to bring
her back to Albuquerque by the end of
the film Troy and Gabriella realized
that breaking up isn't the solution do
you think that these two high school
sweethearts managed to stay together
let's go and find out college
relationship transitioning to college
from high school isn't easy especially
when most of your friends are attending
different schools but just because two
people attend different colleges doesn't
mean they'll stop talking overnight
Gabriella always knew that she wanted to
go to Stanford University but her plans
began to change when she started falling
for Troy but being the level-headed
woman that she is she chose to pursue
her academic goals Troy on the other
hand was never as determined as
Gabriella
so making his own decisions didn't come
easy Troy spent most of his life letting
other people call the shots but meeting
Gabriella changed the way he saw things
so when it came to apply to colleges
Troy finally made a choice for himself
for the longest time Troy's dad didn't
take his love for theater serious
so he continuously tried to enroll Troy
in the University of Arizona where he
could focus on his basketball career but
Troy wanted to attend Berkeley where he
could pursue both of his passions and on
a-plus note Berkeley was only thirty two
point seven miles away from Stanford so
as far as college relationships go Troy
and Gabriella had a pretty good chance
of making it after all they only lived
over an hour away from each other
so they could easily have seen each
other on the weekends to keep their
relationship alive on-again off-again
Troy and Gabriella were just kids when
they met so it's not too surprising that
they broke up and got back together a
couple of times but could this pattern
have followed them to college we're
inclined to think so
juggling a long-distance relationship
classes assignments jobs and studying
isn't an easy thing to do so we're
pretty certain that Troy and Gabriella
would have broken up midway through
their freshman year despite wanting to
be together the lovebirds are very
different people
gabriella wants to become a lawyer and
let's face it becoming a lawyer isn't
easy and requires a lot of studying so
we would expect Gabriella's stress
levels to be at an all-time high but
when it comes to Troy he's more
laid-back and social so on top of that
Troy is pursuing basketball and theater
so we probably want his girlfriend to
watch his games and shows but Gabriella
is a busy lady who puts her career
before all else with this in mind we
imagine that Gabriella and Troy
schedules would be too hectic to handle
causing a rift in their relationship but
since they love each other more than
anything they probably got back together
over the summer only to break up all
over again for twins they're gonna have
to express soul-searching all anybody
wants is to be seen for who they really
are
unless your tiara of course but let's
face it she isn't the nicest girl in
town in fact some might even say that
she makes Sharpay look like a saint but
let's forget about her and focus on Troy
and Gabriella these two lovers see each
other for who they are
and they encourage each other to be the
best versions of themselves without Troy
Gabriella would be an overly shy girl
who doesn't stand up for what she
believes in and Troy would be a
professional athlete filled with regret
but in the end
everyone needs to do some soul-searching
of their own so after breaking up in
college we suspect that Troy and
Gabriella will be in dire need of some
soul-searching so perhaps they will do
some traveling to clear their heads but
a clear mind doesn't bypass a heavy
heart so their soul-searching could have
brought them back together once again
the break anyone who's seen friends
knows that going on a break isn't always
the best solution but sometimes going on
a break is better than breaking up with
school and work pulling in at full speed
we imagine that gabriella will start
turning into a brand new person at this
point she might be interning at a
prestigious firm and overworking herself
and Troy could be getting drafted into
the NBA with little time to dedicate to
each other Troy and Gabriella might
agree to go on a break and sadly this
could lead to a huge fight most of the
time being on a break means that you're
allowed to see other people
so we suspect that Troy will start
seeing someone else despite still being
in love with Gabriella so imagine this
gabriella finally gets some time off
work and goes to Berkeley to surprise
Troy during one of his games but when
she gets there she sees a certain
cheerleader hanging off Troy's arm and
leaves this would be more than enough to
break up the couple but the story
doesn't end here so keep watching seeing
other people after officially breaking
up with Troy Gabriella starts to get
close to one of her coworkers at first
she does this to get even with Troy but
she ends up genuinely liking her new
love interest Troy on the other hand has
broken things off with whoever he was
seen but his efforts weren't enough to
win Gabriella back at this point
Gabriella starts applying to law school
and decides to apply to Harvard she gets
accepted and breaks things off with her
new boyfriend
meanwhile Troy has seen a handful of
girls but none of them compare to
Gabriella so in a desperate attempt to
get her back Troy shows up in her dorm
room and he soon finds out that
Gabriella is leaving for good he begs
her to stay but she says that she can't
so Troy lets her go Troy's future
Troy was offered a basketball
scholarship at Berkeley where he played
college ball until he was drafted into
the NBA Troy played professional
skeeball for two years before realizing
that there was something missing news
life so he went back to school to
complete his theater degree after
graduating
Troy moved back to Albuquerque and
became East High's new drama teacher but
he didn't stop there wanting to pursue
both his passions TOI also became the
coach of the basketball team
despite dating a few girls here and
there Troy hasn't committed to any
long-term relationships and his constant
dating has given him a bad reputation
but this doesn't stop him from becoming
one of the best teachers East High has
ever seen
Troy ends up buying a house in his
hometown and offers to plan his grades
10-year reunion Troy's life is going as
planned and he's happy but there's
something or someone who could take his
happiness to the next level Gabriella's
future gabriella is exceptionally bright
so much so that her teachers don't know
what to do with her a fan named Ava
Wilford wrote an article about where she
thought the High School Musical cast
would be in ten years and we have to say
that we agree with her for the most part
she believes that Gabriella will end up
graduating from Harvard and practicing
law in Cambridge but here's where our
prediction differs at this point we
think that Gabriella will be engaged and
planning a wedding
however she'll keep her engagement to
herself during the rare moments she
talks to Troy on the phone and she'll
opt against telling her fiance about
Troy which is pretty suspicious
Gabriella graduates at the top of her
class and becomes one of the best
lawyers in town despite having a perfect
life Gabriella finds herself dreaming
about the past so when she gets a
10-year high school reunion letter in
the mail she immediately books a flight
to Albuquerque the high school
sweethearts are about to meet face to
face problem is Gabriella has a big fat
ring on her finger and Troy sure to spot
it from a mile away
high school reunion are we the only ones
who wish that the original High School
Musical cast would have returned for one
last movie probably not but can you
imagine how amazing it would be to see
Troy and Gabriella fall in love all over
again a die-hard fan named HSM YouTube
took it upon himself to create a teaser
trailer for the grand
Union this trailer shows Troy and
Gabriella living separate lives but it
gives us the impression that the
ex-lovers are going to get back together
again
so to continue where we left off Troy
and Gabriella come face-to-face during
the reunion and burst into song they
share a magical night together and by
the end of it
Gabriella confesses to being engaged the
news hits Troy like a ton of bricks and
Gabriella returns her fiance the
following day but she soon realizes that
Troy is her soul mate and breaks off the
engagement together again after breaking
up with her fiance Gabriella quits her
job and moves back to New Mexico she
rents an apartment and takes a job at a
local firm once she's all settled in she
surprises Troy during a Wildcats game
and confesses her love for him
Troy is over the moon and his reputation
for being a heartbreaker finally comes
to an end
Troy asks Gabriella to marry him by the
end of the year and she moves into his
house Gabriella decides to open up her
own practice and becomes a highly
respected lawyer she does plenty of pro
bono cases and is finally doing what she
loves the happy couple invites all of
their old friends to the wedding and
they sing and dance all night long after
a few years
Gabriella gets pregnant and gives birth
to a beautiful baby girl and a few years
after that the couple welcomed a baby
boy to the family Troy and Gabriella are
finally living the life they always
wanted the final chapter
life is good for the high school musical
sweethearts and we're happy to hear it
by now we imagine that Troy and
Gabriella are focused on raising their
family and accomplishing their dreams so
while we won't be seeing any of the
original cast in High School Musical 4
we're happy knowing that things worked
out between our favorite couple although
they had a rocky start it's nice to know
that these two soul mates
ended up together it's been 13 years
since Troy and Gabriella graduated from
East High and it looks like it's time
for a new cast to take over the
franchise unfortunately we won't get to
see Troy coaching the Wildcats but
that's probably because the new male
lead will be interested in soccer and
Nas basketball so what did you guys
think about this
bully ever after which who have done
things differently let us know what you
think really happened to Troy and
Gabriella in the comments below
make sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
High School Musical videos to come your
way thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]